i don't like this wine not my cup of tea
not feeling it at all this is probably a
pass for me and for everybody who's
watching this this really stinks this is
not what i would consider world-class
wine it's not completely knocking my
shirt off i don't want to get naked for
you what you just watched is me panning
wine that my father's wine store was
selling literally would do a show where
i would taste the wine that was in the
store cases in the basement bought not
inspect and be like world do not buy
this wine when you make content for the
world you make content for the world
don't mix your business interests in but
the punchline is too many of you are
making content that you think is value
for the audience but it's selfish for
you to use it as a trap worst case
scenario or as a gateway best case
scenario to a sale i make content for
you close the door and then occasionally
i make content for me and when i make
content for me it's very clear hey buy
this but when i'm here for you i'm
[ __ ] here for you and that started
from day one for me with wine library tv
too many of you are trying to be cute in
that kings is where your missed
opportunities are